Thank You Hana and welcome to this event
based around the famous or infamous
quote by Teresa May if you believe you
are a citizen of the world you are a
citizen of nowhere a quick question just
to kick us off who here believes they
are indeed a citizen of the world
excellent welcome the metropolitan
elites we are still fighting on and we
fight to win well done so this is a sort
of rally more than a more than a debate
I do have a couple of admissions just to
kick us off not only do I work for that
bastion of liberal elitism the BBC
although of course if it is a conspiracy
that would that would suggest that needs
to be some form of organization behind
it but that for anyone whose work there
will know that's absolute rubbish but
secondly I have also been to dance the
the Davos man I have met and rubbed
shoulders with the the capitalist
megalomaniacs who basically run the
world to the detriment of not this lot
because we're all in that same elite but
certainly the detriment of most people
in Britain a slightly more serious
question actually taken from David Goode
has remarkable book which we will also
see touch on hugely this this evening
and it is a question which I would like
you also to answer and this is the
question put your hand up if you agree
with this proposition and we can test
the very representative British audience
here with what people actually answered
in this YouGov poll in 2011 so if you
agree with this question do raise your
hand
Britain has changed in recent times
beyond recognition it sometimes feels
like a foreign country and this makes me
uncomfortable who agrees with that
proposition excellence I would say
that's in the below 5% category the
number of people in Britain who agreed
with that statement was 62% so you are
completely disconnected from the rest of
the world and I hope you can enjoy that
thought as you walk home stepping on the
heads of the poor downtrodden people who
live elsewhere in this great country so
let me introduce the fantastic panel we
have who are going to take us through
this often delicates often controversial
touches on interesting debates around
immigration around culture of course
around economics which is the area I
look at most closely and it truly is an
expert panel to my direct left though
not politically is David good heart the
head of democracy of the demography unit
at the think-tank policy exchange and
the founder and former editor of
Prospect magazine his recent book the
road to somewhere the populist revolt
and the future of politics certainly one
of the most influential pieces of work
in this debate coming out post brexit
has been rightly on The Sunday Times
best seller list to his left
David Landsman former diplomat who ended
his Foreign and Commonwealth Office
career as ambassador to Greece he also
worked in what was then Yugoslavia
oversaw the end of Libya's WMD programs
and was ambassador to Albania apparently
a model we're going to be following
after we leave the European Union he is
currently the European head of the
Indian head quartered Tata group to his
left is Elif Shafak award-winning
novelists and political commentator
she's the most widely read female writer
in Turkey she's published 15 books ten
of which are novels
the most recent of which is three
daughters of Eve welcome Elif and on the
far left of course Simon Schama one of
the UK's best-known historians at the
moment presenting the new civilization
series for the BBC's University he is
University professor of art history in
history at Columbia University in New
York the latest of his many books is
belonging which is the second volume of
his history of Jewish people the story
of the Jews welcome panel thank you so
much for joining us I'm just gonna go
through that first question and in brief
order from David to Simon do you believe
let's try an answer this in a sentence
we will have further time for
expositions a little later but do you
believe David you are a citizen of the
world in a sentence no I do not believe
I'm a citizen of the world because to be
a citizen you have to be a citizen of a
state and I'm glad to say there is not a
global state so none of you are citizens
of the world I am very happily a citizen
in the United Kingdom David Leslie do
you know I suppose I should because I
felt very at home in every country I've
lived in that's quite a few I'm sure
most of my friends come from well beyond
a 50 mile radius of where we're sitting
now but do you know I think I'd feel
rather arrogant if I if I were to say I
was a citizen of the world so no Ellis
what's your sense about your citizenship
I think metaphor from Rumi the great
poet he used to talk about living like a
drawing compass one leg of a drawing
compass is quite stable fixed rooted in
one place meanwhile the other leg draws
a huge white circle around that so I
have a very strong attachment to this
country as well as to Turkey to Istanbul
I think that's possible and at the same
time I see myself as a world citizen and
the global sword so you could be many
different things I can be many things at
the same time Simon do you believe you
are
a citizen of the world yes I'm also a
British passport holder and in your
British passport holders despite having
lived in America for more than 40 years
I'm also a permanent resident alien of
the United States of America and a
probably the most passionate tribal
allegiance usually historically doomed
Tottenham Hotspur Football Club I say
but I do remember and I don't quite
agree with this actually but it was very
much in my in my memory when I said
Isaac Deutsch oh the biography a
biographer of Trotsky came to my
Cambridge College when I was a baby dawn
and someone said to me mr. Deutsch er
brother aggressively what are your roots
and he said I'm a Jew and trees have
roots Jews don't Jews have legs very
good now so David good heart kick us off
just try and frame a little bit of this
debate why has it become and maybe
obviously touching on on your book the
the people from somewhere and the people
from nowhere why do you think it has
become such a part of our of our
discussion both culturally and
economically is it linked back to the
events of the financial crisis and what
flowed from that or is something else
going on no I think our society has
become our societies have become miles
more open economically and culturally in
the last 30 years or so and one might
say that the the people I described as
the any where's the the people who
support openness and autonomy we were
comfortable with rapid social change
basically won all the arguments in the
last 30 years and we now talk about
don't we we talk about how open V close
has replaced the old left V right well I
think that's a very self-serving way of
looking at the world actually I've never
met anybody who wants to live in a
closed society but a lot of our fellow
citizens think that the forms of
openness we've had
have not served them well economically
culturally and so on as we saw from that
opinion poll that you described earlier
and I think what in her
I'm afraid typically clumsy way to
resume was pointing it at a very obvious
truth it seems to me now of course she
could have recurred and probably should
have prefaced her remarks by saying it's
fine to be internationally minded it's
fine to be internationally connected I
was going to said earlier I'm like I
feel very internationally connected I
lived in another European country for
three and a half years I can speak the
language of it Rasta Li but nonetheless
she was pointing to a basic fundamental
truth which is that whether it's our
freedoms our welfare particularly the
least well-off people in our country and
indeed just a sense of belonging for all
of those things we require successful
strong nation states and and national
social contracts and I think what she
was saying was that too many people are
disentangling themselves from those
national social contracts particularly
some of the most affluent some of the
best educated some of the most
influential people in our society and
that diminishes our unfragmented our
society and it is absolutely fine
to be you know to support international
openness indeed to be post national so
long as you also respect the vast
numbers the much greater number of
people who still find national
attachments extremely important to their
lives
and what is not fine is to believe that
because you have disentangled yourself
from national attachments to some tit to
some extent and and think of yourself
more internationally because you you it
is not fine to do that and then think
you're morally superior to other people
it is also not fine
to believe that you have transcended
tribe I'm like because on the whole
citizens the world I think have not
transcended tribe they belong to the
anti tribe tribe
you know and and I live in Hampstead I
know what I'm talking about it it's also
I think not fine to caricature quite
mainstream views quite mainstream
national attachments as xenophobic I
think the point that I think liberals
find it very hard to take on board is
you can be strongly attached to grouped
nation to locality and also not fear or
dislike the other now obviously the
history of nationalism in the 19th and
early 20th century suggests that you
know that you can also there are also
forms of nationalism that that have led
to that but I think we know we've we've
been through that we've come out the
other side one of the great achievements
of the European Union indeed was to kind
of recreate the modern liberal open
nation-state so I think we can have
attachment and openness but openness can
go too far and I think a lot of our
fellow citizens have used the
opportunity of the ballot box to to
constrain what they think as the as the
over internationalized elites economic
and cultural they've not push a bit on
this liberal group as you described
maybe the elites or whatever they might
be the people who become detached have
won all the arguments having we been
having a huge debate for decades and
certainly since the large amount of
European Union immigration into the UK
from the a8 nations a massive debate
about immigration it's rarely off the
front pages of many of our newspapers
even if you go back to Davy Blanca and
Tony Blair and Charles Clark they spoke
regularly about immigration the
immigration feel is is that a what is
that a it's out of one argument but
don't mean that's a very good example
it's one of those things that is in
effect been removed from the Democratic
contest I think this is another of the
things that you know people like us are
happy to see things removed from the
Democratic contest we understand that
for the world to be govern effectively
things often have to move beyond the
level of the nation-state you know the
the kind of technocratic liberal
technocratic remainer class
quite comfortable with that partly
because there they have a quite a lot of
sovereignty in their own private and
professional lives but I think a lot of
people feel the loss of sovereignty when
things are removed from from the
Democratic contest you know whether it's
is immigration immigration what exactly
has not been removed as it but it has or
rather politicians have simply not
responded I mean we you know this is the
second great wave of post-war
immigration began in 1997 with the Blair
government and it was then turbocharged
after 2004 with a huge inflow of people
from the former communist countries and
I think a lot of people felt they were
experiencing a kind of double whammy I
mean it with people had sort got used to
the idea that we lived in more open
economy your factory might close and
move to a lower-cost part of the world
but then a whole population of people
were imported to compete against you in
your own labor market in the service
sector jobs that you might then be doing
and we discovered we could do nothing
about it I mean this is clearly the
single biggest not the only bits the
single biggest reason for for the brexit
vote and so we know we have had opinion
polls have for the last 15 20 years
we've had consistently about 75% of the
population saying immigration is either
much too high or too high and
politicians have either not wanted to
respond or post 2004 haven't been able
to respond so I think it is one of those
things but there is if it is in the
basket of things that have been taken
out of the Democratic contest and put in
that sorry you can't decide on this you
know Independence of the Bank of England
much more judicial activism and some
adjuvant majoritarian Human Rights
judicial activism you know all of those
things in their own terms may be
perfectly good where they have shrunk
the Democratic space and you can bet
your bottom dollar when something is
taken out of the Democratic contest it
will be decided according to the
priorities of the anywhere people Simon
that the liberal elites have failed
haven't they that's what they've done
the people are stoke-on-trent voted
brexit because of the failure of
politicians
well actually I want to if you'll allow
me ignore your question actually I think
I I respect and actually agree with a
lot of what David said and I think what
we're stuck with in Teresa mayor's
formula it's a it's a classic example of
a false dichotomy the anyway somewhere
also with respect strikes me as a false
dichotomy
you can absolutely and I don't actually
recognize whether in this room or in
London the sort of sense in which
actually if you feel in some
philosophical sense a citizen of the
world
you necessarily belong to some kind of
free-floating anywhere interchangeable
identity most most of us who actually do
have some sort of empathy with with
people all over the world or who think
actually ultimately it matters for
example like climate change borders and
barriers don't make a whole lot of sense
in the long term do not for a second
think that that dilutes their strong
sense of British national identity and
culture so I think the whole premise I
think is relatively benign we put in
this country but as you know Kemal I
live in the United States where which is
certainly not benign and there was a
certain amount after the break sit vote
of people being screamed at on buses who
were not polish or Romanian a Bulgarian
they were your color and from your
origins and the scream ran go home
actually two people and the issue is
really what it's become and as I said
it's a lot of what David says I
absolutely respect and agree with but
what this has become in the kind of
poisonous zone of populist politics now
is the sense actually that's having a
devotion to your national allegiance
essentially means stigmatizing and
demonizing others your sense of being
able to be British or American or
Belgian I was talking a very angry taxi
driver the other week presupposes that
this will you know a world of flowing
population
we'll all somehow go away as the lega
who've just been elected this morning
into a very prominent power could only
organize mass deportations so I think I
think I absolutely sort of get agree
with David that if we really were
completely just really part of some sort
of nebulous interchangeable you know
nomadic liberal course that that is
really but I just don't recognize that
as so we live in a kind of cyber sphere
really where you know that our little
machines we float around and there
that's actually created a stronger sense
of wanting to belong to an identity
which I don't really like to call tribal
but I you know I don't mind calling that
for the moment
but so in fact all in all sorts of ways
there is absolutely nothing wrong with
national passion until it starts to say
it starts to pick out who actually are
you know can be truly of our country and
our community and those who can't and
one I don't agree with Tony Baird my
whole lot but he actually said you know
when people walk down a street in
Britain and say I don't recognize my
country anymore
they are not talking about Romanians
Simon Romanian side
so I'm as I'm at the chair will ask you
the question again but do you think you
have you have failed to win the argument
because of a lack of understanding of
how some people that David speaks about
feel about that the answer is very short
yes yes I do believe that's true and I
do believe why I think David's quite
right echo bubble arrogance of the media
a sense I answer it in this way a
certain sway of the story as historians
unfortunately do I was befriended rather
wonderfully by the great Isaiah Berlin
mostly to try and keep you out of
trouble failed at Oxford used to gives T
and he was working very very
interestingly on the you know modern
national identity was sort of invented
in the 18th century by Johann Gottfried
herder and and the very strange Johann
Haman and Isaiah who was an absolute
valerian who's one of his favorite
people was Alexander health's and the
much-traveled Alexander Hudson and I
said how can you you know why do you
want to do research on these people who
are larger and soil or partisans who
said look Simon be very nice if we all
thought like the Baron de Montesquieu
but the vast majority of people dead
they they I seem to be getting back to
football all time this is what as I said
they they feel like football supporters
and he meant it in a sea it not that we
knew anything about football
but what he meant was that nationalism
actually calls to our emotional and
visceral sensation that that's how
humans are wired and I think it does
actually approve those of us who you
know imagine that the world is
constructed out of thought to think
about that but I also want to say and in
that sense there is that there was a
kind of tone deafness and there was in
the election which produced Donald Trump
as well I think although a lot of that a
lot of that election absolutely turned
on race and not on a sense of economic
neglect that was much to over reported
this whole issue goes back
rather wonderfully a long long time the
great you know against a resume I would
like to put up Plutarch really there's
an unfair context in day moralia there
was an incredibly moving beautiful mini
book on Exile and plutocracy trying to
console somebody who's been banished
from his home in Sardis and isn't that
it's the sort of founding test and
Plutarch doesn't say and he's trying to
console people remember city-states and
he's living in the second centuries
living in the the Romana Hellenic world
oh really fierce of course famously
fought a bitter war no Peloponnesian
wars so he's not trying to say these
allegiances aren't real but they are
actually a very deep but then he says
something he does said we are not born
into a nation out of nature his point is
which is a wonderful consolation but
also if you're Jewish and you know I
remember my father who who could you
know on Saturday morning recited
passages from the Bible by heart
on Sunday did the same as Shakespeare
felt it was unproblematic those
identities what Plutarch says he says
you become part of the country by the
the use it makes of you and the use you
make of it in other words by residence
really
and what was sitting in a city where the
Mayoress Sadiq Khan
where I hear Michelle Hussein every
morning were saved Javed is in one party
and trickery muna is in the other that
sort of world was something which was
horrifying to Enoch Powell you know who
thought it was fundamentally that the
possibility that we had someone like
Sally Carla's Lord Mayor was the end of
Britain and it yes yes well it's not the
end of breath thank you son um and if
you touched on this notion of
[Music]
you just telephone this notion of your
compass being routed in in many
different places and sort of just just
done made me remember you know James
Baldwin's famous phrase on identity
being like a flock of starlings that
rests on different trees at different
times when you look at this debate and
as you've lived in Britain for a long
long time but with your background is
this a debate that is peculiar to what
I've sometimes described as the worried
rich it's it's the peculiarity of
developed Western economies to be
fearful of what it has brought or is
this a debate that is had in Turkey and
in other countries in a in a similar
manner you know what I find interesting
is the anglo-saxon media discovered
populism relatively recently but in
other parts of the world we have been
discussing this for such a long time
including in continental Europe
including in prosperous relative very
prosperous countries such as Sweden you
know all crisis ridden countries such as
Greece and of course Turkey is a very
important case study in itself because
so much of what's happening in Turkey in
my opinion holds the important lessons
for anyone who cares about the future of
democracy anywhere you know because it's
it's only happening in Turkey it's
happening in different countries one
after another in different degrees and
there are similarities there are echoes
but as I was listening to Simon I was
thinking about this another thinker from
the from the past from history the the
Greek thinker durjan yoginis who saw
himself as though as a world citizen he
came actually from from a town in Black
Sea which is an in Turkey today in in a
town called Cinna so it's not we have
his statue right every year in a you
know every couple of months mobs of
Turkish nationalists go there and they
try to pull down the statue saying why
do we have the statue of a Greek
philosopher in the middle of
town and to me the whole scene is a good
example because that is what nationalism
does to us first of all it makes us
forget our own history Asia Minor
you know Greeks take so many communities
living together contributing throughout
history there's no such thing as a
homogeneous identity there never was but
that's what they make us think that's
what nationalism does to us it really
shrinks our minds and I think it shrinks
our hearts as well so maybe we need to
make a distinction between nationalism
and patriotism we can love our country
what is more natural than that you know
to love where you come from your
cultural belongings your friends your
history these are beautiful values but
nationalism is something else
nationalism requires an us-and-them it
requires a dichotomy and whenever there
is a crisis it will come with as a
package with the assumption that US is
eventually
better than them so we need to make a
distinction there just like we need to
make a distinction between faith and
religiosity we need to stay away from
these false dichotomies this is not we
don't have to choose a side between
identity and non identity I don't want I
don't like identity politics but what I
like is belongings floral fluid flexible
so when I look at myself is I'm an
Istanbul light I'm quite attached to
Istanbul but I'm also from the Aegean
from the Mediterranean I carry in my
soul so many elements from the Middle
East I'm a European by choice by birth
this is where I was born and the values
that I uphold and I have become a
Londoner and I'm very attached to this
country why can't I be many things at
the same time so all I'm saying is we
have to be careful about this all around
the world as we are speaking extremist
ideologies are saying the same thing
they are telling us we can't be
multiples we can't be plural that's the
definition of extremism it's anti floral
anti multiplicity they're telling us are
you Muslim you can only be a Muslim are
you Dutch you can only be Dutch who says
that you know our main element is water
I can be much
things so I think we need to start by
rejecting the identity politics and the
categories that they're trying to push
us into all over the world can you can
you recognize it I hope I I sort of
phrased David's arguments correctly but
can you recognize that the arguments
that are made not by you but by people
who make similar arguments can seem very
exclusionary and can seem to ignore
people who are proud of their country
and have a patriotism but that doesn't
mean they are therefore immediately
portrayed as being extreme that they
that the liberal approach to nationalism
very quickly allies Patchett ISM with
extremism I I disagree I just think I
don't think this is true if I may come
back on that I think we have to make one
thing very clear
not everyone who voted for breaks it is
a xenophobe how can anyone say that not
everyone who voted for Trump is an
islamaphobe or not everyone who voted in
a certain way is a racist how can we
ever say that of course not that's
ridiculous and to be honest I think one
of the biggest mistakes that Hillary
Clinton made in the in the run-up to the
elections was to call half of trumps
voters a basket of deplorable that was a
huge mistake
so we can be critical of people like
Trump in my opinion we should be you
know populist demagogues everywhere but
it's quite something else to connect
with the people to listen to people if
we don't that would be our big mistake
so definitely I understand and I can by
no means be little the huge inequality
not only economic inequality but also
cultural gaps emotional gaps we never
talk about emotional gaps with but we
need to care about this we need to put
more thought effort into that but here's
where I differ the populist demagogues
also are telling us that they are the
spokespeople for the real people and I
want us to be very careful about that
dichotomy who are the real people
unreal people you know what is what does
that mean it's it's a shift of elites
yes one elite is losing ground but let
us understand that marina pan is no less
elite than the people she's criticized
and she is also part of the
establishment so many of the figures
like Viktor Orban Kaczynski one after
another in every country they're also
part of daily except it's a different
thing it was a different world view but
they are an elite and this is exactly
what italian sociologist told us Pareto
at the beginning of the 20th century he
was talking about the shift of the
elites you know it's a pendulum back and
forth but by no means we shouldn't say
that oh this is a war against of the
real people against the corrupt elite
that is another false dichotomy that
they're making us believe in Thank You
Elif David Landsman it's your view on
why this debate has become so much part
of Britain's national conversation and
similar to relief you've lived many
countries in the world and work there as
well in Europe where do you think and
North Africa where do you think this
debate sits in terms of its importance
in Britain and the comparison with other
places you have worked I think that's an
interesting question I think there's two
sides to it I think it is it does seem
to me more acute here it seems quite
acute in the US I didn't feel it so
acute in Greece for example when I lived
there I don't find it so acute in India
when I visit now I'm not saying I'm a
great expert on either country so others
can disagree but I think that there is
something distinct about perhaps it's
sleep that the Imperial feeling whether
it's the imperial past or the Imperial
quasi present of the of the US because
if you've got a sense of my country as
something revolutionary
as something bottom-up as it were you
can identify with that very much more
easily my country top Dan encourages a
certain liberal thinking that there's
something wrong with that there's
nothing wrong with being in favor of
India and Indian independence the the
business I work for is both very
socially responsible but very
nationalist in a sense it has a very
strong sense of nation-building and
that's a perfectly reasonable thing if
you're an Indian to want to build your
nation here I think there is it it's
easier to distinguish between between a
kind of an imperial grandeur that you
wish to reject and a and the sense of
patriotism and people can question
patriotism when you've got so much if
you like historical baggage but I think
there's another dimension to this which
I think goes much more widely and I
think it's actually quite important to
take this beyond national identity
that that's what that's the presenting
problem if you like but I think there's
that there's there's an issue behind
that we're in a we're in an age of
globalization we're an age of increasing
complexity technical complexity and
other kinds of complexity there are more
and more specialisms there are more and
more experts it's a phrase we've heard
quite a lot of back
it's a knowledge economy we're becoming
more intellectualized
greater meritocracy in many ways and
ain't meritocracy breeds a sense of
arrogance and breeds a sense of
entitlement and if you're setting the
rules and we keep hearing about makers
and rule takers if you're setting the
rules there are some people out there
who will set the rules to suit
themselves and we've set the rules to
suit yourselves
you're perceived as skewing the society
on your favor and then you show some
arrogance to those idiots out they don't
quite understand so we get to a
situation in which people people we all
depend on the people whose cultures we
all depend on people who services we all
do
begin to think that we are somehow
belittling them but we're also skewing
the system in favor of ourselves and
against them and then what do you do you
resort to all sorts of identities in
this David I think it's fair say so that
his book you you have a a local identity
or national identity that you that you
resort to when you feel that the world
is coming in on you so I think there is
a sense in which those of and I'll say
us because we had a poll at the
beginning but I think those are from us
and you've all got to be super
intelligent to her wanted to come to
intelligence squared the first place
those of us in a privileged position
part of the meritocracy some way or
another have to be careful about that
arrogance we have to think less about
entitlement and more about
accountability we have to think it's
it's it's very easy to treat treat the
people out there the public I hate it
when I I you listen to listen to the
radio people talk about the public you
know they're my clients out there no
they're our fellow citizens we are part
of a society and I think we have to
think rather more about the relationship
team we definitely throw the baby out
with the bathwater the citizens of the
world the meritocratic we know who's
going to say that meritocracy is a bad
thing but we don't want to throw the
baby out with the bathwater so the
phrase that comes to my mind and it
sounds very out of place what I hope is
at least provocative is a nob less of
leash we know we are I mean I remember
being told at school don't don't be an
intellectual snob you've got huge
privileges you've had a hugely good
education you're rather bright don't
abuse that and I think it's that sense
of abuse which we have to guard against
because you know I think I would agree
with them fine and citizen of the world
a citizen of nowhere doesn't bear huge
philosophical analysis it wasn't I think
intended to it was a line at a party
conference and full disclosure I was
present in the room when it was uttered
and it got a it got a lot of warm
recognition around the room it wasn't a
philosophical
this disposition said but I do think we
have to look in the mirror a bit why do
you think she chose it the Prime
Minister chose to say it well IIIi don't
know but bazooey
it went down well so presumably to that
extent it just the political it was a it
was a judgment which II was signaling to
brexit voters when she that they would
have a home in the Viktor Orban it goes
down very well when he describes George
Soros as a rootless cosmopolitan
conspiring to subvert the will of the
people in Hungary you know he probably
he was very clever man started out as a
liberal you know it was one of the
inheritors of the post communist regime
but he knows of course that is precisely
the danger they destroying it in me I'm
not making crass comparisons with the
rise of the Nazis I'm really not but you
start to smell a sense in which
something you I mean it's it's an elite
thing to know you're superior to the
slogans you mouth and you know and then
you you laugh about it actually it what
a tremendous uptake it gets oh you know
three hundred and fifty million pounds
in other contexts on the notorious bus
of course it was rubbish we knew it all
the time but you know it listen don't
mess up
there's always dog whistle here is in
the end your whistling is the noise of
our contemporary politics now but I left
most likely to say a little bit to you
David yeah I think it's also a pattern
that we see across Europe in a way it's
an indirect impacts of populist
movements because they are changing the
language of mainstream politics and
oftentimes politicians feel almost
cornered we've seen this pattern in
Holland like mainstream politicians all
of a sudden adopting a much more
nationalistic rhetoric because otherwise
here it's wielders is going to occupy
that voice and you don't want him to
occupy that void so what happens this
mainstream politicians start to speak in
more tribalistic if you will tone we see
similar things I mean they all
feel pushed in that direction and that's
the danger of populism in the long run
because even when it's not in power when
it is in power it's another danger but
even when it's not in power it has the
impact it has the ability to change the
tone of politics I think what we aren't
talking about is the fragility of
democracy itself you know many of these
parties are very happy with with with
elections but they're not happy with
liberal democracy with pluralism we
shouldn't confuse majoritarianism with
with democracy and for a proper
democracy to thrive to survive we need
more than the ballot box more than fair
and regular elections there's too much
emphasis on that but not enough emphasis
on the surrounding components that make
a democracy viable sustainable in the
long run such as rule of law free media
definitely an independent academia which
is what Hungary lost Turkey lost Poland
is losing right now definitely women's
rights minority rights together with all
these components you have a functional
democracy so what I'm trying to say is
we take it for granted sometimes but
democracy is something we constantly
need to put effort into and we can very
easily lose if we only reduce it to
majorities and because from
majoritarianism to authoritarianism as
we've seen in other parts of the world
it's a very short step no time to hold
on hold on David David David I mean I I
do think that the citizens the world do
you have to take some measure of blame
for the fact that we have a crazy
demagogue in the White House that we
will have a clown or the friend of a
clown running Italy that the EU is
partially unravelling that the Middle
East is on fire I mean we have had
hyperglobalisation that has been
supported by pretty well all the parties
of centre left and center right in in
this last 25 30 years of liberal
domination economic and cultural liberal
domination and we are seeing a
rebalancing I mean some ways this is
democracy working and on what I don't
hear enough
of is people trying to actually think
hard and distinguish between what one
might call legitimate populism and
illegitimate populism I think quite a
lot of the reader the rebalancing we've
had is is completely legitimate and is
actually an expression of moderate
nationalism of patriotism as Elif would
describe it moderate nationalism I think
is generally speaking a force for good
it binds different kinds of people
together in national societies and and
and Simon I think you know was was
partly guilty of this this caricature
that I was talking about earlier that we
you know we're essentially seeing the
masses as as kind of nascent xenophobes
the whole time and I'm concentrated but
you know focusing on on the blip you
know the hate crime blip was a very ugly
incident it lasted three months and then
it disappeared again and you know if you
look at the if you look at the opinion
polls I didn't invent this is not an
argument anyway some ways these are
world views they're there in the British
social attitudes surveys you know and
it's if this is one of the reasons that
that we do have a slightly sharper
divide in this country is that we have
twenty twenty five percent of the
population the people I call the anyways
who tend to be mobile and and highly
educated the two things go together in
this country which you think I think is
why we have a sharper divide nobody who
voted remain knew anybody who voted for
brexit and vice-versa
partly because of residential
universities my party because of
residential university brexit is well
yeah I don't know very many bricks it is
you're very you're very unwell maybe
that respective but but i but i think
that we have a sharper divide in in this
country partly because of residential
universities that that you join the kind
of liberal professional classes and you
no longer go back and and live where you
came from and I think that that divide
has been particularly particularly
strong here actually less rather less so
in America where half the students live
with their parents but I do think that
you know that you know the ordinary
people of Europe are not on the whole
xenophobes you look at the data there
are people who are you know about five
to seven percent of people who really do
believe pretty malevolent malevolent
things but the vast majority of them are
not and they have seen the European
Union
suppressing even their own moderate
nationalism I'm the very fact that you
cannot you know that you cannot
discriminate in favor of a British
National Citizen when it comes to the
labor market the welfare state social
housing etc because of of the principle
of free movement I mean that offends
against a common sense idea of moderate
nationalism Simon isn't the issue
David touched on both Dave's are touched
that there has been an arrogance to the
arguments made by the Liberals let's
just described them as Madame you might
decide that description and that the the
people who do not agree with some of
those positions on things like free
movement of people on the fact that I
can be a citizen anywhere in Europe have
felt themselves to be ignored well I
actually think there is the discussion
to I I was actually interested to have
examples from David's David landsman's
point that there's a kind of constant
stream of condescension superior
arrogance by by supporters of remain or
by as if you know but people who think
you you can't be citizens or belong to
many different places but if it's if
it's whether or not there would be a
discussion about immigration and
absolutely in favor of that you know but
what I don't recognize is and I you know
what I absolutely don't recognize this
characteristic of those of us who
actually have a more open attitude to
immigration particularly sort of in the
United States as sort of this endless
sneering I mean if the accusation is
that we are arguing for meritocracy and
education Wow
I plead guilty to that altogether and
let me you know again without worrying
you with too many American examples but
this is where I live
last week or the week before that the
Immigration Service in America changed
took out of its
statements the the sentence that the
Immigration Service was designed and
instituted to help realize the dream of
a nation of immigrants and subtitle of
Jack Kennedy's book but it was also the
substance of what made America special
all the way back to Hector Santiago
Africa in the 1780s who said this is the
one country in the world where it
doesn't matter where you come from it
doesn't matter what language you speak
doesn't matter what religion you profess
or none as long as you subscribe to
certain political democratic principles
and so far from you know I think again
David Landis once said well America is
sort of bottom-up nature mate what's up
gents and you correctly do that's or
maybe I misunderstood you that you said
that's why it has a very it's likely to
have a strong populace that for
countries with power either have ER or
had power yeah there's there's likely to
be a difference between the approach
where you're you're looking at you're
feeling of superiority and then you'll
reject you're resisting that your sense
of India and Britain were that different
yeah but I don't think most British
people have a sense of superiority no
longer we have a sense of specialness no
no a purity has been replaced by you
know British national identities no
longer as a sense of we're we are top
dog nation as it might have been in the
18th thank you very much to be brief
because that's an anecdote about the
Immigration Service was to do with
something which is front and center in
American life right now and that's the
status of the 800,000 children who were
brought in by parents who illegally
immigrated and have known no other
country except the United States but
they've lived in this you know legal
no-man's land and the proposal really as
a result of an extremely kind of
suddenly nativist exclusionary
search of in in the United States is to
actually end up deporting them and that
seems to me extraordinary have become
American in the Plutarch Ian sense by
living there by becoming part of the
community Mike that was my grandparents
were legal as far as I know one set from
Turkey the other set from Lithuania they
became absolutely British you know by
living here by becoming British so the
citizen of the world bit inside me
believes in the nobility of the
immigrant experience and the possibility
of having had that immigrant ancestry
and passionately embracing you know
British culture and British patriotism
and how can we bring some of these
debates from those who agree with Davis
position to those who agree with Simon's
position how can we bring those groups
together surely the challenge for
leadership is not so dog-whistle for one
side or the other but is to try and
bring together some of these arguments
do you see ways through the situation we
own or do you feel belief about to the
situation we're in yeah I think the
first step should be recognizing the
importance of emotions this is a subject
that's often underestimated in
mainstream political theory but I think
we live in an age in which emotions very
much guide and misguide politics both
national and world politics of course
economy is tremendously important but
all of the issues that we're debating
right now are very much shaped also by
perceptions our fears our thoughts our
perceptions our anxieties this is the
age of anxiety it's stage of anger it's
stage of resentment frustration and all
of those emotions are incredibly
important and they are understandable
many people yes they do have worries
about the future of their children
whether they're children are going to
have the same job opportunities that
they had yes many people I am
no I I totally understand this are
worried about immigrants maybe a refugee
influx maybe let's make be more blunt
Muslim immigrants you know diluting
their culture let's talk about all of
these openly and honestly if we cannot
talk about these things and if we
belittle people's emotions and this is
where I criticize liberals and left in
general then we will be pushing these
peoples with all their in you know very
sincere feelings we will be pushing them
towards the lap of the far-right because
that is the only open space where those
emotions that are recognized and let's
be honest I think populist demagogues
are doing a better job than other
politicians in terms of connecting with
people's emotions so that's one step
forward I think it is our responsibility
all of us we have that responsibility we
need to go beyond our echo chambers we
need to go beyond our digital echo
chambers so yes we must have friends who
have voted in different ways
it is very narcissistic other way
otherwise anyhow I mean if all friends
if all of our friends think like us talk
like us dress up like us it means we
just want to be surrounded by our own
mirror image that is a very narcissistic
existence so all I'm saying is I'm very
worried about this polarization because
we have seen again in many countries
demagogues benefit from that
polarization that is why they're
constantly stoking that you know and we
have to be smart and go beyond that to
duality yeah I'm gonna be coming to the
audience in a couple of minutes do look
for uh shoes who'll be walking around
with microphones
David Lance but could I come to just
before we go to the audience the the
question of economics and whether or not
two things are being confused here
that's our notion our southern notion
that the citizens of nowhere the liberal
elites however you might just describe
them have become a huge problem it's not
actually a problem of culture and
society and where you belong and
rootedness but is actually a problem of
pretty straightforward economics people
were willing to put up with the fact
that there were elites in the world when
every year they were slightly more
wealthy
they were the year before and they
believed that their children would be
slightly wealthier than they are when
that broke down in 2008 with the
financial crisis and real incomes have
been falling in large parts of developed
economies people then started to look
for other things to possibly blame but
actually isn't the fact that if we fixed
the economics many of these other issues
will become much less toxic well yes I
think it is a bit about economics but I
don't think it's about simple economics
because I think people are interested in
more than just money
and I think there's a sense here of
something really quite acute and urgent
that we've got to address because of
technological change that's coming along
it's going to it's going to change a lot
of jobs it's going to take away a lot of
jobs it's gonna take away a lot of
middle-class jobs to a lot of people
lawyers accountants a lot of people all
using those jobs going away to
artificial intelligence now I think we
need if we're going to if we're going to
manage this what I think is a challenge
from meritocracy I'm not saying
meritocracy is a bad thing I think it's
a challenge from it I think we have to
think carefully about redefining the
value of work and the value of people
because what we're going to be left with
is a lot fewer jobs of the kinds we've
become used to process driven jobs jobs
where you had to learn a lot get a lot
of experience to perform various
processes quite sophisticated ones over
a period of time they're going to
disappear they're going to go up with
artificial intelligence what are we
going to do what's going to be left are
those jobs which either only humans can
do or those jobs which we would rather
humans can do sophisticated computer
programming writing poetry looking after
the elderly
these are things we either only humans
can do or we'd rather not be done by
robot thank you very much and I think
we're going to have to think about how
we as a society reevaluate the value of
work and the value of people to try to
break down
of these distinctions it's not just
about money Natalie if you don't have a
job you don't have money and you've got
a problem
but even if you know I'm actually rather
worried about universal basic income
because I think it risks just putting
everything too into an economic box and
saying right we'll we'll we'll put the
animal in a small cage we'll give it
some food it'll be happy no people
aren't going to be happy without the
sense of purpose and without a sense of
value and it's that devaluing that I
think brings along with it a lot of a
lot of the unattractive side of
searching for identity David how do you
respond to this this idea that actually
there's been a confusion of two
different issues that people are quite
willing to live with things like
relatively large amounts of immigration
with issues around whether they're
rooted or not rooted but actually if the
economics works that will fix many of
the problems that you raised in your
book no I think it is much more culture
than it is economics I mean that's what
most of the most of the work on on
populist voting patterns will tell you
although I think economics and culture
are also very bad following on from what
Dave was saying it I cannot some culture
often very hard to disentangle from each
other and I think possibly the the the
single you know if I was asked to give
one reason for the brexit vote leaving
immigration aside I would say the
declining status of non graduate
employment my little joke about brexit
you don't mind a brexit joke is I blow
out laugh I didn't I blame brexit on the
masses mass emigration and mass higher
education the fact that we have as David
was saying that we have created this the
kind of gold standard of human esteem
has become got a one form of human
aptitude amongst many others cognitive
ability the ability to pass exams and to
think analytically and so on and we have
so elevated that that we've somebody
wrote me a letter who'd read my book
said a good society has a balance
between the three eighties the head the
hand and the heart and and I think it
sounds bit naff but I think that is so
true in a way and that we have kind of
removed status and meaning from the
other that the other two h's when he
said heart he met we were talking about
labor markets really and what
really meant was emotional intelligence
and as David was saying I mean we need
yeah I mean we will I think see a switch
when lots of jobs to do well you require
a degree of emotional intelligence no to
teach children to look after all people
to work in in in the health sector and
we've historically undervalued of all
those jobs partly because they used to
be done by women in the home and they've
just moved out and into the into the
public realm and have historically been
undervalued and I think one of the one
of our great tasks in a way is to
revalue those jobs and obviously we
don't want to we don't want to dismiss
or undervalue cognitive ability but to
kind of even out the playing field a bit
more so you know half of the population
by definition are always in the bottom
half with a cognitive ability spectrum
so you know we and and I think a lot of
people feel that too much and also that
the the the the tradition of so many
traditional lifestyles you know socially
conservative views that you know you
just have to listen to the radio for for
a week and particularly the comedy
programs to realize you know how you
know that they can a metropolitan
worldview does hold many you know but
perhaps in the most lives in this
country in a degree of contempt and and
I think you know we need we need a we
need an evening out of status as much as
we do of money
I like st. I'd like to make a little bit
there yes so let's have some questions
mic one here would be fantastic to start
us off and then we'll go over is that
might number two everyone yeah
we'll go over to number number two there
yeah thank you might want yes good
evening thank you very much Chris Chava
from Urban Land Institute I have to say
I feel a little bit like a fish out of
water I'm the son of a Chinese father a
French mother descended by from a
Sephardic Jew from India a French
passport first-generation American but I
am delighted to live in London proud to
be a Londoner and very grateful to be a
Londoner so it's an amazing discussion
and I feel like I'm in London but I feel
like them everywhere else but the
question so far a lot of the discussion
has been about maybe the failure in some
ways of direct democracy and it seems
like we've talked about how nationalism
works because it appeals to the emotions
and the alternative is maybe demagoguery
but isn't really this also watershed
moment about democracy itself are there
models including technocratic models
which seem to be working better in many
parts of the world better than
democracies well Ella this is something
you have touched on as saying what I
suggest you were saying no and beware
but the fact is and after the financial
crisis certainly the notion that
democracy and capitalism had to go
together in some manner that free
markets needed democracy to operate
China has surely revealed that that is
not necessarily the case and the
gentleman raises the point that actually
are there other models that people
starting to think well but a discipline
maybe but frankly it's better than this
mess we're in
yeah and that is something I totally
understand and thank you for your
question but what worries me is
especially as you travel throughout
Middle East Turkey the discourse has
changed radically in the past whether
you call it an elite or not but the
political establishment constantly
talked about being part of Europe
or somehow it was as if the direction
was clear you know you never saw us as
part of Europe that's another thing but
there wasn't this much talk about
democracy not being adequate for our
part of the world and now this is the
only rhetoric that you hear across the
Middle East in other words they're
telling us you know what democracy it
comes from Western Europe it's not in
our history it's not our tradition our
customs we come from a different
background we don't need them anyhow
let's go towards Shanghai pact what is
Shanghai Park China Russia Tajikistan
Kyrgyzstan in the right place to be if
you don't care about human rights I'm
sorry so I don't I don't want that to be
the direction you know and that the
rhetoric is well maybe we should have
technocrats led by a strong leader this
emphasis on strong leader if we don't
have a strong leader we will go astray
and we want to revive our golden history
our golden paths and that's the notion
of the Empire kicks in you see how
everything adds up and my fear is around
the world people are losing their faith
their trust in the very concept of
democracy that is very dangerous Simon
do you is there we can understand quite
clear Delos points about the negatives
around other types of models but Simon
is there in history a notion that
liberal democracies could take some
lessons from in terms of how they
operate if people are thinking to
themselves I believe democracy has
failed now you want to argue against the
failure of democracy Viktor Orban has
invented the phrase which is proudly
attached to Finnish party of a liberal
democracy as that a liberal democracy as
there is not an oxymoron also adopted by
schinsky and in Poland this is a
horrifying departure an illiberal
democracy would not let us have this
evening here an in liberal voting range
as in Russia would not make this
possible so far from Democrats beating
themselves up about the terrible
failings that they're supposed to have
not listening to the people or whatever
else they need to go back and read
areopagitica john milton argument for
the freedom of opinion they need to
breathe
Jefferson's doctrine actually about the
separation of church and state they need
to stand up for the independence of the
judiciary in particular and not the
politicization of the judiciary there is
a heroic tradition of defending
democracy for which people have died
over centuries and now is not the time
to scuttle off and say Oh Deary me maybe
a liberal democracy and a strong leader
in the arm is the answer that way lies
the neutering of freedom David is there
same question it has you talked about
the failure of of liberalism and David
lands where you talk about the arrogance
of some of the ways of the argument but
David good heart is there a way that
democracy can be not made illiberal but
that democracy has failed as well these
people because we have elections in
Britain we are a democratic nation how
did our democracy allow in your argument
these liberal elites to get away with it
for so long because people's standards
of living were kind of rising slowly
that and this domination I think this
division the my kind of anywhere
somewhere worldview division I mean it's
something that's only relatively
recently emerged as as powerfully as it
exists now something is only going back
twenty twenty-five years I think that
we've had such a kind a monolithic
domination of cultural and economic
liberalism and people you know their
traditional voting allegiances stock for
quite a long time than they grant you
know a lot of the
for a lot of working-class people moved
away from the labour party invited you
Kip and you used similar changes that
have much earlier as as you said earlier
in continental Europe but like I say I'm
Indian in some ways populism is
democracy working so long as we you know
so long as we can distinguish between
the the legitimate and the illegitimate
now man I think we're also in danger of
crying wolf on this I mean with the
partial exception of Simon right points
to the to the dangerous developments in
Hungary and Poland but in much of the
rest of continental Europe what have the
populist seen in what way has the open
society been threatened by populism I
don't think at you know the Swiss have
bad minarets well so it's slight
inconvenience to Swiss Muslims but I
mean we had the ridiculous burqini
business but I mean that was gonna
laughed out of court
literally racist in Swiss elections
about black sheep and white sheep well I
mean that's it's wrong more than a few
you know no I don't know I mean there
has been a rise in in nativism and
possibly racism in some countries I
don't think particularly in this country
you know I mean it's still a tiny
proportion of people believe that you
have to be white to be truly British in
yeah I think so eight or nine percent of
British people believe that I mean I do
not think that we're on a you know on
you know on the verge of a wave of the
rizona phobic racism there are it's
using some countries but I think we've
got to stop crying wolf about it and and
you know and and anywhere technocratic
elites have got to respond to the issues
otherwise we we have we end up with with
brexit and things like that
you know we've unbalanced that we've
unbalanced with over dhamma we've had a
period of liberal overreach and there is
now a reaction against it then we need
to make sure that that reaction doesn't
take ugly forms as it does in some
places number two and then number four
yep so before I offend anybody I would
like to provide some information about
my background so
an old Yugoslavian born in Germany first
five years there 17 years Turkey two
years Japan one years United States and
most ten years I have been a UK citizen
so my question is especially under
developing countries or developing
countries the citizens of these
countries very much are attached to
their nationality and no matter how many
years they spend abroad or what
nationalities they have afterwards they
will remain Yugoslavian they'll remain
Turkish so what is your opinion about
this what do you think the reasons for
this is why people feel so attached to
their nationality maybe in more
developing wells if you think that's
true David Landon well I think that was
the point which I obviously inadequately
tried to make earlier which is that I
think for our for our intellectual
elites or whatever we like to call them
in countries which are very strong or
have been very strong and have a long
history of domination one way or another
we are understandably rather wary of
that and we want to aim off for it and
we want to emphasize the bad as well as
the good if you come I think from a
country which which where you feel that
you've had to fight for your
independence you've had to fight against
the colonialists or events the stronger
powers over a period of time it's much
easier to have a coherent national
uniform view that you know my country is
a great thing and I'm going to I'm gonna
fight for it easy addresses here do you
think it and that not to be as dangerous
possibly as the debates are in some
developed Western them I think that it
depends entirely on on how what you do
with that sentiment whether you then use
it to be aggressive in some way against
your neighbor or against someone else
then maybe it can be dangerous but I
think there is that sense and it's you
know we've got a lot that we're going to
look through our history and say was
that good was that bad we're gonna have
a lot that a lot of
a lot of people will be ashamed of so
it's easy to end up with a position
where you're saying well my country
right or wrong definitely not my country
is often being wrong if you feel your
country has more often than not being
wronged then it's not surprising you're
going to come away with a much stronger
sense of it smells just very briefly and
so I'm just very briefly with it very
briefly of course every every nation
states has its own official history it's
the same in Israel in Turkey in France
in Russia but where the difference is if
it's a proper democracy you walk into a
bookstore you can find many books that
question or criticize or challenge
official history ography nobody puts
those writers in jail or or Sue's them
with regards to belongings I think
that's that's a beautiful thing you know
you can you can as we've spoken before
but feel attached to many many places at
the same time and carry that in your
soul I really don't see that as a as a
conflict where the trouble starts is
when immigrant communities close out and
and become more inward looking and that
is when more nationalistic religious
extremist views find the fertile ground
to flourish and it becomes much harder
for us women overall I think when
societies go backwards and when they
tumble into authoritarianism nationalism
or extremism women have much more to
lose than men so we have to be more
conscious about that I mean it's totally
fine to have multiple belongings but
open up you know the interaction and and
the emphasis on plurality that you can
have little bit on these that's why we
need it thanks Ali
CC hi hi Kevon T Mitchell American expat
I wrote this down to make sure I don't
forget any
if you define citizenship is a status
granted by a state you can understand
rights responsibilities and the
mechanisms for changing one society as
emanating from the state and from a
particular location what entity grants
global citizenship what are the rights
and responsibilities of the global
citizen and what mechanisms allow a
global citizen to enact change in
global society thank you very much Simon
apart from God a boss man who who sets
the rules so these global elites and
sorry can apart from Davos man who sets
who sets the rules of this gentleman
asks if you are a global citizen what
are your rights and responsibilities and
who sets them well I don't think those
of us who identify it's a very good
question of course actually but I don't
think it's like a question in contract
law or something I mean I don't think
any of us are actually in some general
sense are voting for empathy you know
have really certainly I'm not want you
to sort of produce institutional
sketches or maybe you're you're serious
and question will leave me to ponder
this more but in a much more wider sense
of course actually there are all sorts
of things happening which call on our
sense of mutual let's say mutualism Adam
Smith's absolutely lovely phrase in the
Theory of Moral Sentiments the most
obvious being climate change and the
Paris Accords and after all the
pragmatic bashing and the withdrawing
from making States absolutely formally
obliged to reduce carbon emissions
something was really something was
really produced which suggested a degree
of constructive mutuality and it was
precisely because of that that Donald
Trump made such a tremendous dramatic
performance about walking out of the
global climate Accord for him it soars
as he's doing with new it mutual trade
agreements the psychology really of
going it alone of having your country
first and not understanding that in the
modern world you're necessarily need to
come to sort of mutual understanding
what
in the common good is is really what's
at stake and as I say that I know that
that barely answers you have a
wonderfully full military press room but
I bought on the other hand if you're
looking at the choices that are on
Donald Trump's desk whether or not he's
going to define absolutely what he needs
to do exclusively an American interests
even even when you know there was there
was a moment last week where his own
cabinet said well surely you'll think
about cutting a break for your allies
like Canada and this country in terms of
not imposing a 25% tariff on steel and
10% aluminium and he said no not at all
there not going to be any exception so
it's that that sense of being in the
same boat
I know it's wishy-washy it may be a
piece of kind of liberal elitist
superiority but you know if we're not in
the same boat we're gonna drown and make
a wreck I think Dave you have the happen
to changed the tax laws over the last
ten years under the OECD shown that the
global elites can get together and think
something smells a bit wrong we're gonna
change it yeah I mean you know the the
you know any any moderate nationalist is
going to be in favor of in your
interdependence we live in a much more
interdependent world economically in
terms of climate change and so on person
outside the European Union you know is
still going to be involved in all in all
those processes and there is no such
thing as absolute sovereignty although
we will be able to make you know
decisions based on or not you will face
the famous global bond mark it's kind of
on our own terms rather than as one
amongst 28 but curiously enough we
haven't mentioned the that the most
obvious sort of candidates for
citizenship of the world are the digital
giants and they're not a very good
advertisement for world citizenship are
they I mean in the extraordinary
monopoly power you know playing tax
zones off against each other and yeah
and to some extent of course you know we
do we need color
raishin between nations in order to in
order to be a countervailing force
against that corporate power but we
don't need to be citizens we don't all
need to be citizen to the world in order
that we need to be citizens of our
nation state and our nation states need
to get together and do sensible things
together to make sure that you know
Facebook pays its tax bill number three
and then I'll take number one as well
there yeah number three yeah so I think
the panel is being rather sort of self
fragile Ettore towards anywhere man or
anywhere person because it seems to me
that actually it's someone we should be
celebrating is the sort of mindset that
everyone should be moving towards it's
sort of embracing wider networks there's
gonna be all this technological and
economic disruption as we've heard and
effectively we should be going look
everyone you're in anywhere and never
met a real shame that we've got a prime
minister who's given this quote
excellent number one where's that yes
sorry yes sir
yes hello what would you do with the
people who don't feel like they have a
country to be a citizen of excellent so
David Lansing what would you do with the
people who don't feel that the country
to be a citizen of well I think we've
the the international community over the
over the last 50 60 70 years has tried
to set up structures and systems to find
a place of refuge for people who have
nowhere to go I assume you mean because
they physically have nowhere to go
rather than because they they think in
their minds that they have their there
they're not comfortable they are but and
you know how is that done that is done
by individual countries in the end
getting together signing a convention
and agreeing to take their
responsibility and I think actually
coming back to the previous question and
the celebration of we should be
celebrating liberal elites well yeah at
the word we haven't
we haven't heard much bellies
accountability who are whether it's the
tech giants whether it's any of the
other that will reach are we accountable
to the citizens of the world who are
they accountable to as far as I can see
ultimately they have to be accountable
back into a nation-state somewhere
because otherwise it's all out there in
the ether and there is no accountability
and when people feel there's no
accountability that's when the trouble
starts so yes by all means of course
collaborate I mean I used to be a
diplomat I'm not gonna say country
shouldn't collaborate with one another
you've got to have some accountability
rooted somewhere at some point some and
what about the people who feel to be not
a citizen of any nation how is hell they
can be supported in this debate yeah
they're desperately I mean I'm so glad
that question was right so desperately
in search of anywhere if we you know
look at the three quarters of a million
row hinges who you know until quite
recently assumed that they were part of
me on our part of Burma and don't want
to be accommodated by the Bangladeshis
so they're absolutely in a terrible
limbo I will say actually that like
issues of climate change the other two
great issues if you're looking at it
with your history professors hat on
there are three enormous long-term
dominant problems over the next half
century century one is the fate of the
ecology of the earth the other is the
immense and growing distance between the
well-off and they're not well-off of the
of the world and if we're saying well
the well-off nations can actually shut
their doors they're just simply that's
going to be a kind of unsustainable
position and thirdly there is this great
tidal wave of migration which is just
not you know really going to go away in
over over the long term so we'll with it
without being too apocalyptic and crying
wolf
much these are three actually profound
upheavals that are going to affect
long-term history so the issue of the
displace the art rooted the flotsam and
jetsam of humanity is profound and it's
gonna get more profound as time goes
number three I'll be Swift
I'd like to dovetail back to the poll
that she asked at the beginning and a
point that David Landsman made about the
intellectualization of work and I think
our technology will accelerates
inequality in this meritocratic space I
think the crisis of brexit was as a
result of undignified indecent work okay
and one of the perverse outcomes of the
brexit votes has been a brain drain of
skilled EU migrants and a demand for non
EU skilled migrants as a result of those
skilled migrants leaving so when we talk
about the poll looking around Britain
and not wanting to see the other in our
communities there's gonna be more non EU
migrants as one of the perverse outcomes
of the brexit freud's thank you number
two over here yeah I have a practical
commercial question for David good heart
because I really liked your three H's
division it was very persuasive but I to
me and I'm a 90's kid
it sounds very outdated how is the
English hand going to compete with the
Indian or Malaysian worker who works for
less than an hour a day and does not
have the same rights guaranteed how are
you going to compete commercially and if
you can't compete then how is your
division of three H's going to function
I'll come to you in a second David we're
right over against it now but and it
kind of start on that first point which
was about that again touching I felt on
it on the on the economics of these
issues that people's labor was not seen
as valuable to the
and they have reacted in the way that
the lady described by going towards this
what you would describe as more populist
positions but because they're very labor
was not valuable to them was degrading
totally I think that's quite
understandable and it's something we
openly need to discuss that's why I was
also talking about the role of emotions
and and perceptions the economic
inequality is incredibly important but
how we are treated in the society how
your work is valued or devalued has
tremendous tremendous importance all of
this is not necessarily being discussed
enough but I think what we need to be
cautious about is when we say populism
when we see it as a very innocent entity
in itself populism that is when we start
to make mistakes it's not true but
across Europe except in Hungary and
Poland populism has not brought any
damage that is not true so going back to
David's point I think when we observe
the trends the political trends in the
last decade more than the last decade
what we see is including the far right
and the populist rhetoric becoming more
and more part of the mainstream and
shaping the mainstream and increasing
their votes increasing their legitimacy
if I that's why I'm very cautious about
terms such as moderate or mild
nationalism because you might have a
mild nationalism but it is to me quite
arrogance to assume that well we are far
beyond those tribalistic extremist
ideologies because we're quite solid
here in Europe no place is solid anymore
we're living in liquid times so it's not
it's not like the West's solid rest of
the world is liquid it's not like that
at all and it all depends on another
financial crisis another huge wave of a
refugee crisis and if you you know add
to it maybe a populist demagogue you
have the perfect recipe for another
Oh disaster if we don't address these
issues that you have raised if we don't
address these economic inequalities and
and also the cultural and cognitive
inequalities that often Davos elite have
refused to address all throughout this
time David how do you specific this will
be the last answer as well David how do
you specifically answer the question of
how does how does the the English hand
that the toiling English person competes
with the mass democracies of India as
there's the lady described but
presumably China and many other large
nations where their labor will be far
cheaper yeah I mean this the skilled
manual jobs of the industrial here are
not going to come back in any
significant quantity I mean they were
very decent jobs and they gave people
status but there is still look at you
know more than 80 percent of our economy
is in the service sector I mean I know I
would include it as a manual job you
know being a bus driver it's actually
rather a skilled manual job and it's
probably harder being a bus driver in in
India there are probably more things
rushing across the road in front of you
but you will all you know you are going
to get paid you know 150th of what a bus
driver gets paid in London that's just
the you know the way the world currently
use I mean in India is catching up but
it's got a long way to go I mean it's
just you know it's great to respect to
those those basic jobs that that still
essentially are manual which is probably
50% of the jobs in this country but I do
think the I mean that the point the
gentleman made about anywhere yeah we
should celebrate anyways well of course
we should and we have been you know
because anywheres had dominated our
economy in our culture and our society
we have been cell where we're now living
through a kind of readjustment and some
sort of I think legitimate reaction
against that domination and the European
Union you know is a crystallization in
some ways of of anywhere values
celebrating openness and autonomy
and liberalism and it has been a massive
success for the first 50 years of its
life it was a huge civilizational
success but the truth is since the early
nineties it has become too dominated by
citizen of the world thinking you know
money based post national thinking and I
think most of the mistakes that is made
in the last 20 years which have
contributed to the brexit vote are to do
with with that without mentality the the
decision to go for a political rather
than an economic euro which is which is
caused absolutely an absolute mess for
the euro eurozone economy in the last 20
years as you know better than anybody I
mean the decision to to bring the East
European countries in as fast as we did
and this was partly a British mistake
and then also opening our labor market
in 2004 as we did a decision the
extraordinary decision to abolish
internal borders inside the European
Union through Schengen and then whoops
we forgot about the external border as
it was revealed in the in the refugee
crisis which again contributed to the
BRICS vote so we have had you know we
have had anywhere values running us both
domestically and from Europe and we are
now seeing I think a legitimate response
to that we just have to make sure that
it doesn't take extreme forms you know
as as it has in parts of Eastern you and
indeed in in Turkey Thank You Simon
fight so I'm sorry that the time is
completely against us are we slightly
overrun just one brief summation of this
debate by each of you brainy folk I mean
a couple of sentences I'm going to start
Simon with you I'm gonna end David with
you but it must be brief because we're
already over time Simon a summation are
you pessimistic or optimistic about this
debate about citizenship and the
nationalism well I'm incredibly
optimistic about the fact we were able
to have polite disagreements in a
liberal democracy here this evening and
thank you very much for it I'm
pessimistic along with a leaf I so
endorse her point about being too
complacent about
moderate nationalism staying moderate
and if it's if it's a quality of being
you know it if I'm overintellectualizing
instrument okay two things have really
happened just in the last two weeks
which were extraordinary to me in which
were unthinkable have been not produced
by fringe 10% parties genre depends
memoir has become a best-seller in
France and at the party that's going to
dominate the right-wing coalition in
Italy is devoted to resurrecting the
memory of Benito Mussolini that's when
moderate nationalism takes us it's time
to fight back for citizens of openness
and if very briefly pessimistic or
optimistic maybe after listening to this
debate I don't know which is which you
feel more or less optimistic I guess I
like Gramsci's approach you know he used
to talk about the pessimism of the
intellect and the optimism of the hearts
and I think we need both because that is
part of the problem isn't it this
pendulum back and forth
please remember early 2000s there was so
much optimism me both in academia and
media article after article predicting
how we were all going to become one big
global village nationalism was gonna
disappear religious was gonna religion
was going to become redundant and it was
the triumph of the liberal order end of
ideology end of history you know we've
read so many articles in that the
direction and now in 2018 it's the exact
opposite
completes the integration of liberal
democracy of the word liberal suddenly
became a negative thing from one end we
have swung to the other end and we're in
this you know wave together so I think
we need to step outside this dichotomy
let's be half ism stick half of the
mystic we have enough reasons to be
pessimistic but also we've only talked
about how states are going to
collaborate I'm not as interested in the
collaboration of states but in the
collaboration of citizens of civil
societies you know the kind of
collaboration and solidarity that goes
beyond national
among women I'm on miner among
minorities among youth this is what we
need right now so that kind of global
solidarity and global sisterhood is
something that I passionately believe in
Thank You Elie David
David just very where the time I'd have
been off the Today program by now so
David Landsman pessimistic or optimistic
about the future of this debate and I'm
optimistic we mustn't throw out the baby
with the bathwater
there are good citizens of Britain there
are bad citizens of Britain there are
good citizens of world there are bad
citizens of the world we've got a look
look in the mirror and remember you've
got to be accountable to our fellow
citizens so we have to make the effort
to explain we mustn't treat them stupid
David good odd I mean two very quick
points well I mean I think the
alternative to the kind of moderate
nationalism that I've been talking about
is not some sort of global version of
the European Union it is the kind of
extreme nationalism that the the YouTube
fear so we you know we have got to hang
on to the best things that we've got the
other thing that kind of more
philosophical final point I'd like to
make is I do think that you know if
everyone is my brother then sort of
nobody is my brother we simply don't
have the the come emotional and the
financial resources to to spread that we
have to we believe everybody believes in
the civilized world now in the in the
moral equality of all human beings but
we don't believe we have the same
obligations to all human beings and I
think that is sort of the sitter's in
the world fallacy I just want to end for
a very short quote from Jonathan Franzen
who puts his absolute brilliant in the
us novelist trying to love all of
humanity may be a worthy endeavor but in
a funny way it keeps the focus on the
self on the selfs own moral or spiritual
well-being whereas to love a specific
person and to identify with his or her
struggles and joys as if they were your
own you have to surrender some of your
self thank you thank you we all love
each other in here that's a good thing
thank you
your patience thank you - Simon le David
and David
thank you very much as well for you